coronavirus isn't going away so the
world must find ways to live with it
better ways of testing for it more
effective ways of treating it most
importantly eventually a vaccine against
it the partners are many the goal is one
to defeat this virus an EU led virtual
pledging conference aims to channel
billions of dollars into the global
response it's not just about pouring
money into research but also about
pooling resources and expertise for the
common good remain expose the US isn't
involved and while China is offering to
help there are concerns the world's two
top economies already at political
loggerheads may engage in a vaccine war
Donald Trump has already claimed a
vaccine is just months away scientists
point out that even if a vaccine is
discovered in months it'll be a lot
longer than that before it's scaled up
and available to the billions who'll
need it which is why it's so important
to find drug treatments that work in the
meantime both are central to the funds
being pledged and both are at advanced
stages of trialing and research here at
the University of Oxford professor
Martin Landry is leading the world's
largest clinical trial into coronavirus
drug treatments a project called
recovery he's hoping to find an existing
drug or combination of drugs that works
to save lives well before a vaccine
becomes globally available I think cure
is probably too strong I don't think
there'll be a single drug that suddenly
wipes out the krona virus but I think
effective treatments are in sight and
they're critical they're critical
because patients are dying today and
tomorrow and the day after and even with
the best one in the world we're 18
months off having a scale
vaccine at best we need treatments that
deal with the problem of now only in
Europe and parts of Asia are there real
signs of an infection slow down
globally new cases of Kovac 19 are being
reported at more or less the same rate
as they were a month ago feels a
greatest for the developing world where
social distancing is inadequate or
impossible the greatest hope lies in a
global effort against a global threat
jonah hull al jazeera oxford